Cool experience of African Americans and
the United States.
Uh,
you have to start with the experience of
slavery and the vestiges of slavery in
terms of the trump,
the trauma associated with it.
And I think that,
um,
you know,
blacks continue to experience a trauma
in,
in certain ways,
and certainly with respect to,
uh,
those who live in urban communities that
are,
uh,
sort of a infested with drugs or that
are particularly violent,
those are traumatic situations that they
experience on a daily basis.
Certainly as we've seen and in recent
events,
interactions with the police can be,
again,
particularly traumatic.
So when you talk about mental illness
and the black community,
I think you have to began with the
experience of trauma and how trauma
continues to abound and,
um,
and their experiences and their in their
daily lives.
I think that what happens for a lot of
individuals is that they suffer in
silence,
um,
with respect to having a mental illness.
And so what I mean by that,
in the greater society,
there are certainly a lot of stigma
associated with mental illness.
Um,
it's sort of antithetical to the
American ethic,
which is to,
you know,
be strong and courageous to pull
yourself up by the bootstrap to weather
the storm,
etc. I think the second part of that,
you know,
point is what's happening at the
community level or the society level.
And I think what happens is that within
the black community,
um,
I think that again,
you know,
that ethic about what it means to be
strong and courageous,
um,
is particularly pronounced because,
of trying to,
you know,
combat those forces like discrimination
or racism.
Um,
and you know,
it just adds to the burden of,
you know,
sort of what it means to survive.
And so then the person who is struggling
with the mental illnesses perhaps not
embraced or you know,
warmly accepted because of their
struggles.
You know,
I remember,
uh,
as a,
as a young person growing up,
I used to hear about the person who was
quote unquote sitting down south.
I used to wonder what that meant.
And it wasn't until I got older that I
became more knowledgeable of the fact
that a purse,
that person was struggling with a mental
illness or perhaps substance abuse.
From a historical perspective,
there's been a lot of emphasis and the
black community,
particularly in back families,
uh,
on keeping your problems close to the
vest and the home,
you don't share what's going on with
outsiders.
No one can treat you as best as your
family can.
You bring all your burdens and your
problems to your family.
And if you do take it any to any entity
outside of your family,
it's the black church.
The church is really important in the
black community and make no mistake
about it.
It's a,
a source of,
uh,
you know,
sort of salvation and uh,
and the healing and there's a whole
collective support,
uh,
from,
you know,
you get from your fellow church goers
and that sort of thing.
But I think also what has historically
happened is died.
Um,
the church has been defined as the place
to sort of relieve your symptoms or to
address your burdens.
And so it stops there.
And what I think needs to happen is
that,
first of all,
I think pastors and lay ministers can be
more trained,
uh,
and the signs and presentations of a
mental illness.
But I think that the church could be
sort of a triage unit,
if you will,
such that it identifies those who have
needs and it's that sort of first step
and the sort of entree into care.
But it shouldn't stop there.
I believe that culturally competent care
is critical to everything.
If patients perceive that providers are
inauthentic and do not care about their
unique circumstances,
then they're likely to be turned off at
our baseline.
Providers should understand there the
history of their neighborhoods,
for example,
or the history of the experience of,
uh,
of African Americans and Latinos,
um,
such that they can put the clinical
presentation into context and understand
what unique factors,
um,
are in play with respect to the clinical
presentation and how that person is
seeking to,
you know,
survive and live in the world as an
African American or Latino.
And so I think that it's the onus is on
the provider to understand that context
and to understand what it means,
uh,
for that person to live in that context.